thank you all for being here it's nice
to see all of you it's nice to see
familiar faces it's nice to see students
past and present always and nice to see
new friends as well I'm extremely
honored that I've been asked to deliver
this lecture to you a lecture named for
no less than Rosa Parks and Martin
Luther King a daunting assignment but
what Rosa Parks and Martin Luther King
and their comrades and their ilk remind
us of is who are we to shirk
responsibility who would we be to step
away from offering what we have to our
communities so thank you Dean Attridge
and thank you to my beloved
indispensable colleague and friend dr.
Emily towns for inviting you to continue
marking the King holiday as it moves
forward and continues to make us think
and thank you to everyone else who made
this visit possible when I was growing
up of course there was no king holiday
to celebrate it's still a happy measure
of progress for me that we have the
national holiday even though many fought
to keep that from happening and we still
have to make the day up here at Yale of
course for a piece of my growing up
never forget that we have to make it up
of course for a piece of my growing up
dr. king himself was alive and I thank
my parents for taking me in 1963 to the
march on Washington in a baby carriage
because there was no question in their
mind that they should go and no question
in their mind that the baby should be
there as well though neither of them
could know how the day and the words of
that day would be live on in history and
how the words spoken on that day would
live on as sacred words in remembering
the March my parents always tell me two
things one that though we remember dr.
King's astonishing speech it's
unforgettable language and powers of
analysis its rhetoric its invitation to
the audience and audience
is for years to come in the call and
response of its rhetorical construction
to do better it's tough challenges its
sheer beauty the march was not just
about dr. King and those words it was
organized in large part by a Phillip
Randolph and Bayard Rustin there were
women doing the footsoldier work as
throughout the civil rights movement as
throughout all movements there were
extraordinary measures taken by so many
people pre facts pre cellphone pre
Twitter to organize all those people
peacefully in one place it was a small
miracle and so progress goes the work of
communities of many sometimes
exemplified by the charismatic one who
holds the message who has the words in
by home growing up we had a small candy
dish on our shelf in the family room
filled not with candy but with buttons
political buttons from various causes
and campaigns there was a campaign
button for the first black candidate to
become a mayor in Mississippi there was
a SI SE puede yes we can button from
cesar chavez United Farm Workers
movement and there was a button from the
march on Washington a button which my
father wore to Barack Obama's
inauguration 46 years later an image of
a black hand shaking a white hand and
the words jobs peace freedom in the
midst of the soaring rhetoric we
remember all those words on that day the
purpose of the march on Washington was
in part to seek equality in jobs with
the understanding that once those
barriers were removed once everyone had
a fair shake to have a job with which to
support themselves and their families
and move through life with the dignity
that self-reliance confers then so much
else could begin to take care of itself
that is a struggle that is yet
unfinished but I want us to think about
the words intertwined job peace freedom
a poem unto themselves distilled an
economical memorized abell repeatable
useful I'm going to speak today a bit
about dr. King's use of language and the
sacred words and also about the work of
three African American poets
amiri baraka June Jordan and Lucille
Clifton to explore this title African
American poetry as the sacred word the
legacy of dr. King is certainly known
through acts but his words are also one
of the ways that we remember him and you
only need to imagine if dr. King was not
gifted with language how would we
remember him how would his message make
its way forward that's another way of
saying that there is no dr. King as such
without that language without his
language and I think that his
meditations his sermons preached on the
streets and not just from the pulpits
and not only to the faithful our
meditations that stay with us today but
the question of faith not only who are
the faithful but where do we place our
faith in better community in Beloved
Community that question of faith is a
large one we now have a corroded Civic
political discourse we had one then it
was just in different places but one
that has visibly eroded in the last few
years even though its previous Heights
were never olympian so the challenge to
our community is how do we think of our
words and shape them to carry maximal
meaning to understand the stakes of
precision of language why do our words
matter and what are their actual power
my question for this evening how does
African American poetry let us think
about that I think that black poets
encounter the sacred with the work that
we do every single day for black life
and black history are nothing if not
responsive to the call for a sacred
response to the annihilating properties
of black life over the hundreds of years
on these shores where might we find
succour where might we find guidance in
our communities in our activism in our
churches in our families in our food and
in our music our songs but what about in
our poems and what is a poem that
language which demands that we return to
it that which even when folsom is
distilled and essential that
which aspires to the condition of music
that which is thrifty in the
african-american tradition where thrift
is a necessary value a hallmark a mode
make a way out of no way make do make
something out of nothing and so then
poetry an art form that comes for free
an art form that is economical and an
art form dr. King spoke of love as an
ethic someone should write a
dissertation someone may have written a
dissertation and just go through all of
his writings and think about how he uses
the word love and beloved that would be
very interesting the necessary guiding
force in our lives yes we know what love
is on one level I love you you love me
we love our children we feel it in our
hearts it feels good but what about the
harder kind of love that also guides us
and spurs us too difficult action what
about love that makes us say I think you
are wrong and this is why I think you
are hurting yourself and I want to help
you stop what about the love of country
that made a Martin Luther King say to
the highest powers in the land you are
wrong and you are denying us justice and
we demanded or the love of country that
would make us speak out against Power
now it is love which makes us say we can
do better we expect better we deserve
better we will struggle until we have
better it is love for our communities
that makes us hold each other to high
standards and ask and expect the best of
each other it is love for ourselves that
makes us honor our temples the only ones
we are fully responsible for King's
legacy is so crucial because we have the
words to carry it forward and so I urge
you to go back and read not only the I
have a dream speech but so many of his
other speeches that when I read them
make me think you know people used to be
much smarter than they are now
in his 1964 Nobel lecture he addressed
this concept of thinking about what it
is to understand not just what you're
fighting against but what are we
fighting for what are we fighting for
and he used the word love to think about
the importance of love that is what he
called quote not emotional Bosh but
rather love of the demanding variety
that gives us a vision quote we will we
will not build a peaceful world by
following a negative path it is not
enough to say we will not wage war it is
necessary to love peace and sacrifice
for it we must concentrate not merely on
the negative expulsion of war but on the
positive affirmation of peace and now a
few more of Kings sacred words speaking
to his supporters at the end of the
Montgomery bus boycott then as a young
minister he declared that their common
goal our common goal was not simply the
end of segregation as an institution
rather quote the end is reconciliation
the end is redemption the end is the
creation of the Beloved Community
Beloved Community sacred words which lay
forth the principle of being responsible
to one another one by one in concentric
circles to whom are we responsible which
child is also your child 1957 dr. King
love is creative and redemptive love
builds up and unites hate tears down and
destroys the aftermath of the fight fire
the fight with fire method which you
suggest is bitterness and chaos the
aftermath of the love method is
reconciliation and creation of the
Beloved Community physical force can
repress restrain coerce destroy but it
cannot create and organize anything
permanent only love can do that yes love
which means understanding creative
redemptive goodwill even for one's
enemies is the solution to the race
and then in Raleigh North Carolina
excuse me in the role of the church in
facing the nation's chief moral dilemma
1957 some more of the same he's working
out over several years this idea of
beloved community and then to talk about
what he's saying about love the type of
love that I stress here is not eros a
sort of aesthetic or romantic love not
filia a sort of reciprocal love between
personal friends but it is agape which
is understanding goodwill for all men it
is an overflowing love which seeks
nothing in return it is the love of God
working in the lives of men this is the
love that may well be the salvation of
our civilization I find echoes and
analogs of Kings philosophy in the work
of all of the poets i'm going to turn to
now first beginning with June Jordan in
addition to thinking about the
challenges of communal love she's also
helped me think about the word itself in
the form of poetry as it appears in
poetry and the actual work that word
love can do which King understood so
well what is the job or work of a poem
and what are its limitations why would a
writer speak in the morning in poems in
the afternoon in their embodied self
while teaching or doing other activists
work and in the evening in prose essays
what can each form do that the other
cannot most specifically what do we want
to protect in poetry if we believe as I
do and as Jordan did that poetry is
sacred speech that marks the sacred in
our lives poets do the work of making
images that compel distilling language
writing with model precision and
specifically that is what poetry has to
offer to other genres it makes something
happen with language that takes the
breath away or shifts the mind for the
poem which after all is not the
newspaper must move beyond the
information it contains while
simultaneously imparting the information
it contains Jordan's commitment to
poetry was constant and it is in those
words that we find her simultaneous
devotion to the largest possible
picture her keen analysis of the world
situation and the smallest detail hurt
ending of language Jordan outlines many
of these ideas in her book poetry for
the people which chronicles her poetry
for the people movement at UC Berkeley
where she taught for many years and it
offers a kind of try this at home
handbook for bringing people together
across boundaries through the power of
poetry in order quite simply to make the
world a better place through reading
writing and performing poetry how
speaking poetry can make you braver to
do the work of learning and knowing so
that when you speak to the issues of the
world you know what you're talking about
and you know what words you use and why
you use them to travel either literally
by learning another language and reading
what people who think and speak in that
language how they see the world not to
trust it to translation that's part of
what she encourages to come together
under the umbrella of poetry knowing not
only what we fight against here to echo
dr. King but also where the love is that
can unite us Jordan quote as I think
about anyone or anything whether history
or literature or my father or political
organizations or a poem or a film as I
seek to evaluate the potentiality the
life supportive commitment possibility
of anyone or anything the decisive
question is always where is the love the
energies that flow from hatred from
negative and hateful habits and
attitudes do not promise something good
something I could choose to cherish to
honor with my own life it is always the
love whether we look to the spirit of
fannie lou hamer or to the spirit of
agostinho neto it is always the love
that will carry action into positive new
places that will carry your own nights
and days beyond demoralization and away
from suicide i first read her poems as a
child in a beautiful collection who look
at me that introduced african-american
art to young people I am black alive and
looking straight at you she wrote which
arrested me as a child which always
seemed to me
to be talking to me and telling me to do
something I didn't know what seemed to
me to be a credo or a touchstone for
moving through this life and its
challenges I am black alive and looking
straight at you I can only say it like
that that's what the words demand sacred
words words that remind us what it is to
be alive fortunately alive proudly black
facing the world and its challenges
words that call us forward a sentence of
poetry on its own without punctuation
all its lessons condensed and contained
and portable and Jordan always wrote
about love whether it be in a whole book
of love poems Haruko or in her constant
asking I am saying the ultimate
connection cannot be the enemy the
ultimate connection must be the need we
find between us it is not only who you
are in other words but what can we do
for each other that will determine the
connection and here we think back to
King's concept of beloved community it
was love in Jordan's unsentimental
vision that could blaze a path through a
world in which multiple scale violence
is the rule and we the word we is the
site of Jordans poetry over and over and
over again real ways of individuals and
communities she has worked with and
imagined wees of the difficult and
optimistic future that calls for our
clear-eyed love and bravery amiri baraka
explored a concept of the sacred word
that ran antithetical e to organized
religion in the poem when will worship
Jesus Baraka makes clear that he's not
interested in the sacred as something
that is Christian or church found or
text born he attacks capitalist
America's intersections with
Christianity and its use of religion to
justify slavery and attempts to
indoctrinate people into believing that
they should endure their suffering using
the suffering of Jesus as a model for
the existential good of their souls
that's not what Barack is about he
writes quote this baraka we ain't going
to worship Jesus because Jesus don't
exist except in song and story except in
ritual and dance except in slum stained
tears or truly
in dollar opulence stretching back in
history stop moaning about Jesus stop
sweating and crying and stomping and
dying for Jesus so then later on in the
poem what is the sacred word that Baraka
offers after he's told us not this not
here not this messenger right what is a
set of beliefs a set of tools based on
the past based on a sharp reading of
history thinking about how to move black
people forward in the present let's
continue what when will worship Jesus we
worship the strength in us we worship
ourselves we worship the light in us we
worship the warmth in us we worship the
world we worship the love in us we
worship ourselves we worship nature we
worship ourselves we worship the light
in us and science and knowledge and
transformation of the visible world and
so then onward to his 1967 poem ha ba ka
' capital be a Kaaba a closed window
looks down on a dirty courtyard and
black people call across or scream
across or walk across defying physics in
the stream of their will our world is
full of sound our world is more lovely
than anyone's though we suffer and kill
each other and sometimes fail to walk
the air we are beautiful people with
African imaginations full of masks and
dances and swelling chance with African
eyes and noses and arms though we sprawl
in great chains in a place full of
winters when what we want is son we have
been captured and we labor to make our
getaway into the ancient image into a
new correspondence with ourselves and
our black family we need magic now we
need the spells to raise up return
destroy and create what will be the
sacred word
that poem was published in the book
black magic in 1967 in this poem black
people confront the essential crimes of
slavery in its aftermath it's sorry
legacies in the form of black people
once captured now still sprawling in
Chains in a place full of winters a
place of closed windows and dirty
courtyards echoing the initial theft the
initial closed portals the initial
impassable apertures the initial filth
of the hold and still across courtyards
across the years across diaspora black
people are still trying to reach each
other make words find words to become a
progressive community that can transcend
its boundaries baraka in the poem
reminds his readers that quote we are
beautiful people with African
imaginations the indelible origins and
sources not only of power but of
expressive power masks and dances and
swelling chance that somehow carry
people through to the present day when
Baraka says we have been captured he is
trans-temporal capture he is speaking
about the literal capture and
transportation to these shores but also
the capturing of bodies and minds and
the needs for tools to vision a way out
we labor to make our getaway and that
getaway is into something ancient but we
cannot go back in time we are no longer
in Africa so what do we take of the
ancient image how is it carried what is
iconic and portable and useful to black
people trying to find a way forward how
can the ancient image which I take to
mean some form of culture bring us quote
into correspondence with us and our
black family the family is no longer
African but rather black diasporic and
we've moved into the present moment the
answers are not easy is it magic we need
asks Baraka spells how to move empowered
to the necessary work to raise up return
destroy and create which echoes that
passage I read from dr. King so
beautifully when he says physical force
can repress restrain coerce destroy
okay remember these are appears actually
Martin Luther King and amiri baraka it's
easy to forget how very young dr. King
was when he was killed so these people
our age mates they are peers I don't
know if King is listening to Baraka I'm
sure he knew who he was I have no proof
I'm just sure and and and certainly of
course Baraka would have known about the
work of dr. King I'm sure and you know
both think of them both of them on black
college campuses and in the in the same
years and in the late 40s early 50s I
mean they're interestingly analogous
actually both geniuses in very different
very different ways so to raise up
return destroy and create that cadence
right even though Baraka is turning from
the church has turned long ago from the
church que sera the poem asks what will
be what will be it asks at the end both
the means and the outcome and then the
only line by itself is a free-standing
stanza is the final line the completion
of the question the final line standing
all alone is the sacred word and how
interesting that the mysterious title
Kaaba might refer to khabar kab a the
holiest place in Islam a large building
inside the al-haram Mosque in Mecca
containing the black stone thought to be
stoned from paradise sent from the
angels by the angels to Ibrahim or the
Egyptian concept of the car and the ba
the car meaning kind of intellectual and
spiritual power very difficult to
translate not quite equal to our concept
of the soul but analogous and the ba
referring to all of those non physical
qualities that make up the personality
of a human being and that also have to
do with power remember the kha and the
ba once joined are what makes it
possible for the deceased to leave their
tomb and join the ba excuse me for the
car to leave the ba and then they can
become an ancestor so Baraka joins those
two words the kha and the ba to make one
a joint ancestor
a holy place and perhaps that word is
then the answer that we loop back round
two after we finish the poem what will
be the sacred word and we come back to
the title that we haven't understood
before Kaaba African invented refigured
what will be the sacred word where will
we find it how will we know it Lucille
Clifton is certainly a poet who offers
us sacred words in the form of poetry
the brevity of her poems is born of
necessity I write short poems because I
have six children she often said but
there's also an ethics to their brevity
they are Cohen's they are accessible
they invite you back in again and again
they reveal themselves over time and
their profundity increases upon
meditation they are useful poems most of
her poems are written in lower case
letters refusing hierarchy like other
poets out of the Black Arts and feminist
movements of which Clifton was not
explicitly apart and the lower case
letters also create an evenness of
reception so that value in the poem is
not assigned by capitalization but
rather through the meaning and the
message itself how those poems
understand gesture how they practice the
pith of mother wit each poem a perfect
thing each word a meditation stone
here's my favorite poem of hers i read
it on all occasions and it's a good
thing that you can hear it over and over
again and take it in I bet some of my
students might even know what I'm going
to read what am I going to read oh no
I'm gonna read that later but no um this
is the light that came to Lucille
Clifton and you know in the end of your
Smith says when you say a word enough
the word becomes you and so I think
that's also why I like to read it out
over and over again because it then
inhabits and and you can possess it you
can have it you can see if you believe
it the light that came to Lucille
Clifton came in a shift of knowing when
even her fondest sureties fade
away it was the summer she understood
she had not understood and was not
mistress even of her own off I then the
man escaped throwing away his tie and
the children grew legs and started
walking and she could see the peril of
an unexamined life she closed her eyes
afraid to look for her authenticity but
the light insists on itself in the world
a voice from the non dead path started
talking she closed her ears and it
spelled out in her hand you might as
well answer the door my child the truth
is furiously knocking the phrase nothing
human is alien to me is ascribed to
Terrence and to Cicero reprise by many
nothing human is alien to the poet
Lucille Clifton in her poems we learned
that to be human is to suffer to be
human is to survive to be human we learn
is to harm others to be human is to
testify to be human is to exalt power to
be human is to notice small things and
name them about a year before her death
two years ago Lucille came to campus
some of you were probably there the
occasion was glorious and the pinnacle
for me was when she came to my class and
held forth from my students an intense
and devoted group who had spent the
semester lovingly and diligently
studying African American poetry from
the 20th century one of those students
wrote me upon Clifton's death to say
that she had kept a copy of the poem
study the Masters tact from that day
forward tacked on her dorm dorm wall and
that she read it every single morning
for her meditation so at that point
she'd been reading the poem every
morning for a year this is study the
Masters Lucille Clifton like my aunt
Timmy it was her iron or one like hers
that smooth the sheets the master poet
slept on home or hotel what matters is
he lay himself down on her handiwork and
dreamed she dreamed two words some
Cherokee
maasai and some huge in particular as
hope if you had heard her chanting as
she ironed you would understand form and
line and discipline and order and
America there were many books in my home
when I grew up at few of them were books
of poetry and I remember that there were
four in particular for books of poetry
so I remember them very well and one of
them which my parents have never been
able to explain to me why that book of
poetry next to Shakespeare sonnets was
Lucille Clifton's good times and that
book opened with the lines here in the
inner city or like we call it home here
we are I read from Washington DC here
someplace that was home as we called it
beyond the reach of sociological
language like inner city that we made me
think of the wii's my parents used when
they meant more of us than those who
were in the room at that moment we black
people we city dwellers we who ardently
believed in this or that we our family
we beyond our family what did we agree
was home as a child I thought I
understood those poems but the miracle
of Clifton's poems is how they turn and
unfold and close and turn again if you
stay with them over the years they are
small and imperfect things to be held to
the light and she played quite
infinitely with the word light in her
poems light loose Lucille Lucifer
accepting the meditations that the word
invited we held Lucille's poems to the
unsentimental light the light that
Lucille tells us that she was it chosen
to receive my students to reminded me
this is an insight that came to me from
a student of the light she showed us
even in Lucifer she writes poems in his
voice illuminate I could and so
illuminate I did and she's always
speaking in her own voice I think the
richest lessons her poems have taught me
our lessons about the proximity of life
to death and the porosity between those
realms Lucille Clifton matter of fact
he communicates in poems with a
grandchild before he is born a husband
after he has died her mother after he
has died there's dreaming and waking
there is life there is death cancer is
cancer there's wellness and there's
illness but within those states there
are many ways of knowing listening
perceiving her poems call upon all those
modalities and recognize the flow
between them every shed I ain't asleep
every goodbye ain't gone that's one of
the things Lucille Clifton's poems have
taught me to trust what the body knows
through the porous scrim between waking
and dreaming between this life and
others sacred words indeed no matter how
elaborate the words they use poets
strive to tell the elemental truth as
Clifton often reminded her acolytes
truth and facts are two different things
so time and again she made luminous
poems premise taan clear truth-telling
but always with a twist and space for a
vocation and mystery physically small
poems with enormous and profound inner
worlds of great poets whose poems arc
into Clifton's I think of Emily
Dickinson's intense compression to which
Clifton adds explicit historical
consciousness of Pablo Neruda's
elemental clarity from which Clifton
subtracts hyperbole just to name a few
they are committed to truth-telling in
the face of silence history and her work
is embodied alive and autonomous always
alert to its contradictions as in study
the Masters Lucia was very funny perhaps
especially in dark circumstances you
have two uncanny you have two uncanny
cure self she said plainly when called
to the side of a strung-out young mother
who was lying in the middle of her
kitchen floor with the children all
about her in disarray to be a poet is to
be another kind of funny that looks at
the world of sku and from unexpected
angles and questions orthodoxies and
those words to those perspectives are
sacred as well and when she spoke of the
volcanic tragedy about living three of
her children she described herself in
the future as quote a pissed-off Negro
in heaven
and who says when I get to where I'm
going I want the death of my children
explained to me so that is also her very
intimate relationship right with these
very very profound and sometimes
seemingly unanswerable questions that we
look forwards to help us understand few
poets also have written so convincingly
of celebration and sacred words are also
words that bear joy that lead us to joy
Clifton invites the reader to celebrate
survival a poet survival against the
struggles and sorrows of disease poverty
attempts at a ratio of those who are
poor who are women who are vulnerable
who challenge conquistador narratives
there is luminous joining these poems as
they speak against silence and hatred
won't you celebrate with me she asks in
the eponymous poem what I have shaped
into a kind of life I had no model born
in Babylon both non-white and woman what
did I see to be except myself when she
died poets who loved her remembered her
to each other in her meditations other
sacred words which did not assume the
form of poems if we don't keep our
stories who will if we don't tell our
stories who will she said poetry knows i
will accept it when it comes she quoted
will Rilke hold to the difficult she
loved to say I comfort the afflicted and
afflict the comfortable and finally I
don't wish to destroy be destroyed by
hate Clifton believed and showed in her
poems that there is but a sheer curtain
between the living and the dead and so
in poems like he arrest and this is the
last of hers that I'm going to read and
in others she often conversed with the
dead crossing those lines without
comment for in her worldview the dead
and living are in constant conversation
this is her poem the death of Fred
Clifton the death of Fred Clifton 1110
84 age 49 that was her husband I seemed
to be drawn to the center of myself
leaving the edges of me in the hands of
my wife and I saw with the most amazing
clarity so that I had not eyes but site
and rising and turning through my skin
there was all around not the shapes of
things but Oh at last the things
themselves that's the death of Fred
Clifton so Lucille Clifton's poems ever
reveal for us the things themselves the
things themselves passing that
particularly african-american way of
describing death seems quite cliff
tonian the living pass out of one state
into another but passing is ongoing and
not finite those we have loved are just
over there just on the other side what
will be the sacred words Baraka asked us
and I think the answer is Lucille has
them like the preacher baby Suggs who
preached her sermon in Morrison's
beloved and Morrison is the one novelist
who I count as a poet and she preached
of course not on the Mount but in the
clearing okay she preached in the
clearing and she just to read a little
bit of this in this here place we flesh
flesh that weeps laughs flesh that
dances on bare feet in grass love it
love it hard yonder they do not love
your flesh they despise it no more do
they love the skin on your back yonder
they Flay it and oh my people they do
not love your hands those they only use
thi bind chopped off and leave empty
love your hands love them raise them up
and kiss them touch others with them Pat
them together stroke them on your face
because they don't like that either
you've got to love it you and no they
ain't in love with your mouth yonder out
there they will see it broken and break
it again what you say out of it they
will not heed what you put into it to
nourish your body they will snatch away
and give leavings instead no they don't
love your mouth you got to love it
this is flesh I'm talking about here
flesh that needs to be loved and then
ellipses the dark dark liver love it
love it and the beat and beating heart
love that too more than eyes or feet
more than your life holding room and
your life giving private parts hear me
now love your heart for this is the
prize more sacred words that I think are
in continuum with Clifton a student of
mine who's now a student of here at the
Divinity School mr. Rodney Reynolds
wrote an extraordinary and prize-winning
senior essay for us in the department of
african-american studies where he
examined the role of poetry in the civil
rights movement in the process of
writing this thesis he did some archival
digging and now I want my students
always to obey me when I tell them go to
the archive and he found a clutch of
letters between dr. King and Langston
Hughes here at the by Nicki and in the
King papers that are held at Boston
University so on November 30th 1959 in a
letter to Langston Hughes martin luther
king jr. wrote quote my admiration for
your work is not only expressed in my
personal conversations but i can no
longer count the number of times and
places all over the nation in my
addresses and sermons in which i have
read your poems i know of no better way
to express in beauty the heartbeat and
struggle of our people and so we've come
full circle I think and I'll leave us
with the meditative words of lengths and
hues and an open invitation to continue
to talk and think with me about the
sacred word and where we may find those
words in in the work of our quiet Sears
our poets and this is just a short poem
by Langston Hughes luck sometimes a
crumb falls from the tables of joy
sometimes a bone is
to some people love is given to others
only heaven so that is luck by Langston
Hughes and so I thank you very much for
your attention and I look forward to
talking with you thank